this video is sponsored by insta360. so
this tiny camera has basically one great
trick that makes it the most versatile
camera that i've ever used so there's
been action cameras and 360 cameras for
a while now i've tried some on and off
for a few years but insta360 asked to
sponsor a look at their latest highest
quality most fully featured version yet
this is the x3 and i'm really glad i did
so here's how it works this camera body
has two half inch high resolution
sensors back to back so they're each
recording a super wide angle video that
stretches way back actually a little
beyond 180 degrees and so since each
camera goes a bit beyond 180 there's a
little overlap at the seams and then the
camera does the work to stitch the two
feeds together into one and then even
better since it knows where the mounting
point is it knows where a selfie stick
would be and it can stitch that out of
the video and then of course it knows
its own exact dimension so can also
stitch itself out of the shot so
essentially it creates this invisible
ball of 360 degree video capturing
goodness which is pretty sick but
honestly the how it works isn't nearly
as interesting as what it actually
enables you to do so check this out you
pair it up to your phone right you can
see what the camera is pointed at which
is me and then when i start moving it
it stays
pointed at me so they named this flow
state stabilization basically it's using
ai to find a horizon and keep that level
and locking on a target somewhere in
that sphere of video and now you're
really getting an idea of the power of
this camera this isn't something you get
just to shoot spherical video really
this is a sphere of video where you can
choose any piece of that sphere to point
at and use and that's what makes this
the most versatile camera i've ever seen
so this x3 is the latest version here to
shoot this way it has a new half inch
sensor like i said it can shoot 5.7 k
360 video with hdr or 8k time lapses if
you want it has a new 2.3 inch
touchscreen with tempered glass and the
whole thing is waterproof up to 33 feet
with an ipx8 rating with an 1800
milliamp hour removable battery inside
and so then the whole insta 360
advantage the whole thing is the ability
to take advantage of the fact that it's
always shooting this whole sphere of
video all the time so if you can picture
it you're just holding a ball of 360
degree video and you can put it wherever
you want
so that opens up a massive world of
possibilities so let me show you some of
the things you can do ranging from the
simplest to the craziest and most
impressive so the simple one is called
me mode you've probably seen this one
before you can hold out the camera on a
selfie stick and it tracks you and
focuses on you automatically this is
already kind of wild that it looks like
there's just a camera floating out in
front of you it can kind of look like a
pseudo drone shot if you move it around
over your head enough but it's basically
just stitching out the selfie stick and
it can export a regular looking
widescreen video from a crazy
perspective so then okay there's what i
like to call gta mode which is basically
using the extended selfie stick mounted
to a vehicle so that it's basically
floating off the back and thanks to
tracking it has this sick like first
person view of an actual car driving
down an actual street you might have
seen some of these shots on instagram at
least i know i have i really like though
this next one which is called first
person mode this is something i'm
actually gonna start using more on the
autofocus channel that we just started
because believe it or not holding a
phone in one hand while driving down the
highway with the other is not actually
the safest thing to do so all you have
to do for first person is put the camera
either on your head or literally hold it
in your mouth and then track the part of
the sphere that faces forward and boom
not only do you have a first person wide
angle shot of what i'm seeing as i drive
but it's super out of the way and it's
very useful fun fact the other side of
the sphere looks like this some people
have called this nose mode you might
have seen some clips like this also all
over the internet but probably the
craziest thing i've seen in this
software is something called bullet time
this is just literally swinging this
camera around your head on a string so
insta360 actually makes a cord just for
this feature it's got a quarter twenty
score at the end you connect them and
you swing the camera around in slow
motion and it can make some pretty sweet
videos kind of an advanced selfie
showing off your environment in 360
degrees so it's a pretty complex system
that's very capable the craziest part of
all this is that it's all edited on your
phone it's all done in the insta360 app
so that makes it this sort of next level
of accessible i've been talking about
starting youtube channel on your phone
making videos on your phone you can do
all this with the camera and one app on
your phone and render times are not bad
either so just going through a clip you
shot on this camera and asking it to
track something it tracks faster than
real time which is sick and you can do a
whole sky swap of a video clip in a few
seconds it just analyzes the whole clip
and then does a pretty solid convincing
sky swap and if you think about it at
all it is much faster much faster than
any adobe app or motion graphics tool
that i've tried but the whole point is
any effect you want to achieve can be
done within the app so whether it's
something super complex like bullet time
or just some simple reframing just
moving around that sphere of video using
keyframing and even using the gyroscope
of your phone to point at new things and
adjust your shot it all works very
smoothly no matter what you always have
the whole sphere to play with and you
can move around and create a custom
video of whatever angles you want super
quickly you can get really creative with
it so this is a 449 camera and the app
on your phone and a selfie stick and
that's it that's the whole system so i'm
going to be adding this to the arsenal
for the autofocus channel for sure there
is also some accessories there's this
guy which is a reader accessory so
instead of having to take out the
battery which is removable
to get to the micro sd card you can just
plug it straight into your phone and
grab files that way there is also a mic
jack accessory so you can plug in via
usbc and then there's a mic jack so
things to like sort of add a little bit
of production quality to this camera
that's already pretty solid on its own
and there's also other smart features
like loop recording which records every
30 minutes and you can use it as a dash
cam so are there any weaknesses
basically the only one that i've found
is with a 360 setup like this with
back-to-back cameras if you put the
subject right on this seam like on the
edge of where the two cameras are
recording or it's stitching them
together you can get some distortion
especially if you're very close to the
camera but it's pretty easy to shoot
around that it's easy to change the
orientation to just make sure
somewhere in the sphere is the subject
and then you're good so yeah
realistically this is the most versatile
camera i've ever seen and actually used
and honestly i don't even scratch the
surface of the creativity that i've seen
people do with these cameras again all
over my instagram feed i've seen people
like throwing this around doing fake
drone shots i saw somebody actually
throw it off of a cliff next to somebody
who was diving and it just fell into the
water but of course the spear captured
the person diving right next to the
camera just cool stuff so naturally i'm
going to be bringing this into autofocus
videos first person driving shots maybe
selfie stick outside of the car stuff
things like that but go ahead and
subscribe over there if you want to see
that stuff i'll have a link below to the
channel also have a link below to the
camera itself and thanks again to
insta360 for sponsoring this look but
that's pretty much been it thanks for
watching
and i'll catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]